- He's an athlete,
actor, and entrepreneur.
He's considered to be one of the greatest,
if not the single
greatest basketball player
of all time.
He's worth over a billion dollars
and his brand grosses over 2.25
billion dollars every year.
He's Michael Jordan
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
(plane whooshes)
- Every day, the first person there,
before the sun,
would be Jordan.
And he was there because he wasn't good.
He would work with a batting instructor
and would work all day long
and be the last person to
leave every night also.
I asked him what it was
like for him in the morning
and Jordan said "I get up
before the sun comes up,
"and I make myself some
breakfast by myself,"
he was down there alone.
"And I get in the car
"and I'm driving to Spring Training
"and there is no one really
out on the roads yet.
"And I look at the seat next to me,
"and I see my dad,
"and I talk to him.
"I think to myself,
"Pops, we're doing this.
"We're doing this together."
(soft music)
And the day would end
and he would say to
the batting instructor,
"Can we do a little more.
"I think I'm getting this.
"I think I'm learning this.
"I think I'm getting this"
And that's when Sports
Illustrated put him on the cover
saying that Michael Jordan
has embarrassed baseball.
And as I would watch him there every night
as the sun was going down
and the other ball players had left
and I would see this guy
working to get better.
Michael Jordan working to get better.
I couldn't help thinking
that if you ever have children,
You ought to pray that they grow up
someday to embarrass you like this.
- I played professional
basketball for the Chicago Bulls.
(frenetic violin music)
- [Announcer] 32 seconds to go.
A one point lead for Georgetown.
Daugherty to Black.
The time 18.
Shot, Jordan, Michael Jordan!
- If I had to trace my evolution,
the Michael Jordan evolution,
it'd always have to start back in college
hitting the shot against
Georgetown in 1982
when I really didn't know
exactly what I was doing.
- [Announcer] North Carolina has won
the 1982 NCAA championship.
- It awakened a person inside of me
to excel,
to compete to excel,
to be one of the best, or be the best.
That drove me.
And I guess with that shot
it kind of ignited a fire inside of me
that nothing was going to stop.
- [Announcer] Jordan down
the middle all the way!
- [Announcer] Jordan to the hoop!
- [Announcer] Jordan down
the lane all the way!
- [Announcer] - Jordan,
who has it on the break,
driving all the way in!
(yelling and cheers)
- I wanted to excel my game
and isolate my game from everybody else.
That I was more than
just, a few dimensional.
Even when it came to Magic Johnson.
I mean, Magic Johnson was a crowd pleaser.
He was a good offensive player.
He was a great motivator.
Average defensive player.
I wanted to change that.
I wanted to take it another step.
I wanted to do all those things
that could separate me from Magic Johnson.
I'm not saying he wasn't great.
He still is great.
But we're are great in
our own different way.
And that was motivational for me.
And to this day it still is.
(funky music)
I missed more than 9,000
shots in my career.
I've lost almost 300 games.
26 times I have been trusted
to take the game winning shot
and missed.
I've failed over, and over,
and over again in my life.
And that is why
I succeed.
I never feel that I am at my best.
I feel I still have room to improve.
I still set goals for
myself to strive for.
I'm never complacent
with what I've achieved
even though it's been
very successful for me.
I still feel I have a lot to prove
not just as a player but
as a person, as a father,
to some extent as a role model,
in all aspects.
So I'm never really too
complacent with myself
or with what I've achieved.
When I get to a point where I feel
I can't improve as a player,
I walk away from the game.
I still feel that I have a plateau
that I haven't reached yet,
in terms of my skills or
my expectations of myself.
I'm always going to expect myself to do
certain things, or surpass certain things.
As long as I believe that then
my road to success is going
to continue to expand.
Sports is a tool that teaches.
It teaches you bad things.
I can also teach you good things.
It's how you perceive those things.
I've looked at every experience
that I've had, negative and positive
and taken that as a positive.
I wouldn't change anything
because I think it would alter
some of the other things that happened.
So When I look back, I can't say that
I've had any bad things happen.
Sure, you don't want bad things to happen
but you deal with bad things.
You can't have good without bad.
It's not about the shoes.
(inspirational music)
It's about knowing where you are going.
Not forgetting where you started.
It's about having the courage to fail.
Not breaking, when you are broken.
Taking everything you've been given
and making something better.
It's about work
before glory,
and what's inside of you.
It's doing what they say you can't.
It's not about the shoes.
It's about what you do in them.
It's about being
who you were born to be.
You know, we're all old.
And sure, we're tired,
it's been a long season.
But mentally we have a vision,
we have a finish that we have to obtain.
Sometimes you have to do it
when you're old and you're tired.
I think it is a test
of your will to succeed
when you have to deal with
some of these negatives.
And I'm pretty sure by
the end of this play-off,
you will see the old and the tired people,
we're very, very young
and strong mentally.
Maybe it's my own fault.
Maybe I led you to believe it was easy
when it wasn't.
Maybe I made you think
my highlights started
at the free-throw line
and not in the gym.
Maybe I made you think
that every shot I took
was a game winner.
That my game was built on flash
and not fire.
(dramatic music)
Maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
that failure gave me strength,
that my pain was my motivation.
Maybe I led you to believe that basketball
was a god given gift and
not something I worked for
every single day of my life.
Maybe I destroyed the game.
Or maybe you're just making excuses.
- [Announcer] The Bulls
can win it right here.
The Bulls can win it.
Unbelievable!
13 seconds left.
Jordan left side.
- I practice as if I'm playing in the game
so when the moment comes in the game.
It's not new to me.
That's the beauty of
the game of basketball.
That's the reason why you practice.
That's the effort.
So when you get to that moment,
you don't have to think.
Instinctively, things happen.
- [Announcer] Jordan drives.
(dramatic music)
And fires, yeah!
The bulls lead 87-86!
Michael Jordan with 45 points.
- You know, I think there
was a very defining moment
of what my career was in Chicago.
- [Announcer] The Chicago Bulls have won
their sixth NBA championship.
- [Announcer] If that's the
last image of Michael Jordan,
how magnificent is it?
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Reynado asked me to,
so if there is a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I will see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of
Jordan's top 10 rules you like the most.
Let me know in the comments.
I'm going to join the discussion.
Thank you for watching.
Continue to believe
and I'll see you soon.